[Music]  these ruins lie deep in the jungle  and if you look closely you'll see  thousands of hieroglyphics which tell  the ancient story of the mayan empire  to call national park can be found in  northern guatemala's potent basin  the park is a unesco world heritage site  due to its extraordinary wildlife and  cultural significance  situated on over a hundred and forty two  thousand acres of jungle it is the home  to amazing biodiversity  the ancient site includes palaces  temples  and even courts for games  all the remnants of a civilization that  thrive from 600 bce to 900 ce  the complex at decal was formerly a  center of mayan culture  at its height she called traded with  cities in mexico honduras and belize  the structures here are some of the most  important archaeological sites left by  the mayans  and a trip to takal  is not only a journey of extraordinary  beauty  but a window into the past  [Music]  you